[Music]
check
hey we're back we are back
i got a topic for you okay warm blankets
all right what is happening to us
what is going on with that warm blankets
it's the topic what's the next what's
the next explainer going to be snuggling
just saying there's physics everywhere
and i just want to sort of
bring warm blankets time has arrived
to come to understand warm blankets
first of all a warm blanket
sounds like a new emo band
secondly i am it's an underused title
for something out there
yeah warm blankets but i will say that
i'm excited to see
the physics in warm blankets
okay so here you go you ready okay here
we go okay
when you look at a coat or a blanket or
an item of clothing so that's a warm
item of clothing right obviously when
it's sitting on the hanger
the temperature of the clothing is the
same as the temperature
of the air okay okay
so you don't say oh that's a if
if there's a blanket sitting on the tile
floor you don't say oh that's a warm
tile
you say oh that's a warm blanket but
they're the same temperature
right if they're just sitting out there
in the air they'll be the same
temperature as each other so why are we
thinking
the blanket is warm but the tile is cold
when they're the same temperature
interesting and the funny thing is
we do make that distinction because
you will look at the blanket and call it
warm
and call the tile cold or cool
even though they're sitting there
together sitting there together at the
same temperature
okay so here's the thing if the blanket
were actually
a source of warmth you could put it over
the tile
wait a while peel back the blanket and
then the tile would be warmer
than the surrounding tiles uh now i just
put your tile
on the floor just going oh man it's
snuggling tiles
oh that was so good i'm tired of people
calling me cold
i wanted
so the point is the blanket doesn't make
anything warm
it it is completely passive in this
it's not a source of warmth if it were
you could put it on something cold
to warm it up okay true that's what i'm
saying
it is not a source it is not a source
even though our
language calls it a warm blanket or warm
mittens
or warm anything else okay so
what we really mean when we
say a garment is warm
is that it does not transmit
heat energy right that's all we mean
even though that's not what we're saying
okay
that that first of all that doesn't
sound very comfortable
i just want to get under a blanket that
doesn't transmit heat energy
new catchy ad for the blanket commercial
right come on under here and let's get
under this thing that doesn't transmit
heat energy
so there's the point if you put the
blanket on the
tile there is no heat
difference between them so nothing is
happening there's no
okay so now watch now i put it on you
so you are warmer than the blanket if
you got the blanket out of the closet
or on the shelf okay right the blank is
just room temperature
you are warmer than the room than the
blanket and right now
you are radiating heat to the air yes i
am using it
because i am hot baby no you are radiant
i am
and so you feel cold because you're
losing heat to the air
okay and then you say oh there's a warm
blanket let me go get it so now you
bring
the blanket and now the blanket
doesn't let you lose the heat to the air
you keep that heat and you interpret
what's going on
as the blanket being warm when all
that's happening is that you are no
longer losing the heat you were
a minute before you put on the blanket
now you might say that's just semantic
no okay because
let's say you you brought in some cold
beer
okay okay so you yeah before you don't
have any ice yet but you got it out of
the
refrigerator cabinet it's cold beard is
sitting on the floor
and you say i don't want the beer to
warm up
let's get a warm blanket to put on it
okay
okay because because how does the beer
get warm
it's taking heat from the air okay
because the air is warmer than the beer
so what you need is
super blanket that does not transmit
heat energy across
its thickness so you take a blanket put
it on the beer it'll keep the beer cold
by preventing heat from coming from
outside of the beer
from entering the beer oh man
so so the point is so the blanket that
you're calling a warm blanket is also a
cold blanket
it's a cold blanket too now and by the
way we have another word for things like
that that you carry around and it's
called the thermos
okay that's true right yes whether it's
a thermos cooler or a thermos
for liquids it's yeah it's it's the
thermos keeps hot things hot and cold
things cold it's cold
right the thermos is the ideal blanket
for the food that's contained within it
so if you wanted to if you wanted the
best bed of them all
turn it into a thermos it's just not
cuddly
but boy you will stay you in fact you'll
become too hot because your body needs
to actually
cool off otherwise you'll overheat so
i just wanted to clarify the fact that
warm blankets are simply blankets that
don't transmit heat energy
and it'll work keeping your beer cold or
you warm
and and more broadly it'll maintain the
temperature of whatever it is it's
covering
there it is and if you're not having a
good time then that's a wet blanket but
that's a whole nother explainer
a whole another that's another another
whole another another
so um so basically this is what
insulation
is insulation we don't think of blankets
as insulation but that's what they are
and if one blanket is not working for
you you get a second blanket
right so the two combined make it even
harder for heat to transfer from one
place to another
okay okay so now
how does that how does that explain
why no matter how many blankets i put on
my wife
her feet are still we have top
scientists working on that right now
how can your feet be cold you're wearing
boots
thermal socks and three blankets how are
your feet cold
food
so we may have talked about this in
another explainer chuck i'm not sure
but you will feel cold if you are losing
heat to your environment
right and you will feel warm if you are
gaining heat from the environment or if
your
heat does not lose to the environment uh
um has a hard time leaving your body
going into the environment
yes so talk about that during wind
chills well windshield we did talk about
that that's right
i had some memory of that so warm
mittens
you know what makes mittens warm they're
keeping your fingers touching
each other right in a mitten
when one finger loses heat it goes to
the next finger
right well you want that heat so you're
radiating to yourself
inside the mitten right whereas gloves
where all your fingers are separated
you it's trying to prevent your skin
from making
thermal contact with the air but you
have all this surface area on each
finger
for each finger of the glove and so
that's why it's harder to keep your
fingers warm
in gloves than it does in mittens
that's all this is ever doing and that's
a wonderful metaphor
for where we are in america right now
america
the country that prides itself on being
a glove
where each finger is independent of one
another
when right now what we really need to be
is a mitten
each one of us giving heat to one
another relying upon
each other in order to be warmed
together
so
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
chuck that was beautiful that'd be
beautiful
kumbaya is great i forgot about that but
but what that
but what that means is if you
jump into if you if you have a partner
in bed who's been there
for some time holding aside your wife's
feet which top researchers are still
working on
if you have a part that's been in bed
under the covers under the
warm blanket and you've been outside and
you
feel cold because you're losing heat
faster than your body is comfortable and
you say i'm going to jump in bed
the moment you jump in bed you will
touch your partner
and start taking heat from them right
the moment you start taking heat from
them you feel warm
and you say oh honey you're warm and
what do you feel like
to her oh my gosh
what i feel like to her is a call to her
divorce lawyer
so so you're taking heat from her the
fact that she's losing heat from you
means she feels cold right so two people
cannot feel warm with each other at the
same time
you can be neutral one will feel cold
the other hot
one will feel hot the other cold but you
both can't feel warm touching each other
thermodynamically that's not possible
nor can you both feel cold
touching each other somebody is either
neutral or somebody's taking heat from
the other
right well judging on my marriage
uh clearly we know who's going to be
taking
what from whom what what kind of heat
energy who's got what
i'm just anyway so that's it that's all
i got to say about about blankets
all right you pulled it off
i'm going to give it to you
[Laughter]
so think of it not as a warm blanket
just as a blanket as a blanket
and serving as a thermos in your life to
keep the cold beer cold
or the hot uh or you warm
right at your body temperature one last
thing before we wrap
reptiles are the same temperature as
their environment because they're
cold blooded that's what cold blooded
means it doesn't mean the blood is cold
it just means they don't regulate it
and they make it a higher temperature so
it's the same temperature as the air
so you could put a blanket on a reptile
but it'll be vastly yet less useful to
it
than if it were warm blooded well now i
feel
bad about making my iguana wear a
sweater
[Laughter]
all that for nothing all that knitting
for nothing
how much knitting could that have been
i know and just quickly if the iguana
goes out into the cold weather you're
going to want to bring him a sweater
because then they will be losing their
body heat to the air and maybe they
don't want to do that at that moment
right okay because they live that way
but maybe they want to stay warm and
snakes you ever see snakes
in the summertime they'll come out and
and sunbathe on the rocks because that
feels good
right but they but that's because a
source of energy is being handed to them
by sunlight right you can't just give a
blanket to a snake and say you don't
need the sunlight just snuggle up in the
blanket
that there that's not going to work
right and the reason why you don't give
a blanket to a snake is because they're
a snake
thanks for figuring that one out chuck
right they just they don't deserve
anything dammit
don't give a blanket to a snake okay
because it's a snake because it's just
what kind of reasoning is that
i don't like snakes that's where that
reason it comes from it's that simple
all right that's cool there you go um
and what i learned
is this if you are using a blanket to
keep your beer warm
i invite you to a little place called
walmart or target
to buy a cooler
because you wouldn't use the blanket to
keep your beer warm you use the blanket
to keep i'm sorry
i said it wrong damn it damn i messed it
up
damn anyway oh well
all right be good chuck this is great
start
explainers over and out keep looking up